things youtube channel and what before i
start do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and bring that notification bell
that way you're going to be notified of
my daily videos while you're at it leave
a comment let let us know what you think
about the topic
on top of that guys okay as you know our
sponsor is cooking with chris okay chris
makes you customized meal plans just for
you you go to this guy you tell him what
foods you like
and he makes you a customized meal plan
just for you okay
the link to that is in the description
and when you guys get the meal plan it
helps support the show so do that on top
of that all super chats will be read so
if you have something that you want the
panel
to read and answer
um super chat and we will read it okay
so that is all of our
that is all the intro so to start why
don't we go around everyone say your
name age okay where you're from and your
relationship status
so i'm adam i'm 18.
i'm from high wycombe but i moved it for
uni and i'm single
hello guys i'm marvin i'm 20 years old
i'm from north london enforced and i'm
single
okay i'm louisa um i'm 22 years old i'm
from south east and i am single
my name is donnell
i'm 21 years old i'm from london
and i'm steady
from london i'm single as well
okay okay guys we already have our first
super chat in the house from the
internet i never forget thank you so
much for the super chat okay so today's
topic yes are you guys aware of what
happened with kim kardashian's son yeah
sure yeah
yeah that was a good tragedy yeah
crazy once though so for for the viewers
that may or may not know
okay
kim kardashian has like a four ish year
old son and he was playing roblox and um
somebody mentioned his mother's
sex tape on roblox
so um
the kids have no idea that kim got
famous through a sex tape
yeah i think that's a bit that's a bit
of a hard conversation to have with your
son to think you know that's what i did
before and it's coming up now how many
years later so it was a bit pink um so
so right now i want to give the men
the chance to speak
so what would you guys
date someone like kim kardashian
that has had
that has had um a sex tape on the
internet i think we can all agree on
this i think we all wouldn't it
yeah
probably date but whether it's a
marriage you know yeah
respectfully humbly and then that can't
be having a wife like
on the sex tape
this on your passes your past and it
read in the future is different don't
yeah that no no comment yeah
um
i mean yeah well but i don't know like
that was your past in it like i guess
for some people you have to do what you
do to make one unit so i mean if you
change yeah yeah but men have to like
get a job
[Music]
like you can make money in other ways
you can go work at mcdonald's you know
like
it's just they want fast money it's not
like if that happens to a dude he's just
homeless
oh
oh damn
drink to that
well
so so you would date a girl that had
like a sex tape like that
okay
abroad like we're saying this now but
that this
[Music]
like i don't know that's the question
because like would it be easier for you
to like leave or would you actually stay
that that's where the problem is off
because
i mean kim k you know everything about
her already so you going to marry her
like you know everything she's done but
with another girl
i mean i'm not gonna lie i probably
would i probably would you probably
still would yeah
why like why wouldn't you pick a girl
that like doesn't have that like if that
was a girl i didn't have the oh of
course yeah but if that's the girl that
i've met then that you like
yeah cause it's just interesting to me
because kanye could have anyone he's a
billionaire like why is he picking a
girl that's for the streets
she's made so much money though so
either way she's actually an independent
woman regardless of what she's done
but then again
yeah but then again
that kind of stuff is a bit of a wild
yeah but i mean
do you imagine do you guys care about a
girl's money
no well not this point but it's nice if
you have money in it yeah it's not just
don't be flashing in my face and saying
i don't need you i don't do this i don't
i can do like is is a woman's ceo like
hot to you
i've always heard from guys that they
don't care about a girl's money so it's
interesting that you guys have the
opposite point of view it just depends
on the situation
so for example like
if i'm older and i'm trying to get my
stuff together
and
she hasn't like for example isn't hasn't
been really ambitious
then why would i like go for her because
it's not really in like i'm not going to
elevate myself to a different point in
life
with her but she's not really she
doesn't have money she's not like
ambitious
so what do you think would you date a
guy
that had a sex tape
um
[Music]
would i
[Music]
i mean
if it's not something he's trying to do
again
like on a regular then yeah i think i
would really yeah oh my god it depends
though it really it really does depend
is it leaked like is it something you're
doing like every year
it needs to have content is that what
they don't it's i don't know difficulty
even nowadays like people are just
recording themselves like it's normal
like that's what i'm saying it's like
it's normal
like guys are just being like yeah
i mean
yeah but like you don't think it's kind
of on the girl to vet the guys she
sleeps with and does that with like
doesn't that kind of say something about
her decision-making abilities
i mean it depends on the situation again
because if it's like a past thing and
it's not gonna be
every week or he's going out to do that
or i'm seeing it somewhere else or my
friend's sending it to me then yeah yeah
it's a bit different but if he made
money and income because of right help
kim kayden then
i don't know
okay so now the other question do you
guys think that someone's past matters
to an extent yes
yes yes
okay obviously it does the reason i say
it does is because
you can enjoy your young ages but don't
destroy it yeah like yeah you can have
fun and do whatever like
but if you just go on be loose and just
do everything like it's gonna be hard to
get like
um like the indistinguisha some girls
that have bc's that are older than their
age so it's like by the time they get
into that stage where they want to like
settle down because you've been around
it's like no one's going to take you
seriously yeah maybe one guy will be
very hard did you get maybe
one ah there's always hope for everyone
in it but you know like maybe one guy
like
well but it's like even if now like you
marry that girl imagine walking down the
road oh yeah like she slopped me off in
the block oh yeah she did
no but that's something you're gonna
have to live with like for the rest of
your life you get it yeah and
like even if you marry her yeah it's
like cool you have to go through all
this time to marry the girl it took me
what two weeks just to get slops
you get it so it's like
well it's kind of like she gave
something
to that guy for free and she's making
you like pay for it yeah yeah
i'm trying to see
if you've got to pick the right person
for you man
whatever you're ready to deal with yeah
i mean if two j-bags meet then they can
be together in it yeah because they both
know what they're on that's crazy yeah
you know i would say though
i would say you like what you like so
if there's a girl that you really like
but a past is crazy
that's not really going to matter too
tough because
you liking her factors more than what
she's done with other people before i
think it depends on like what happens
between when you've started speaking to
her i mean yeah and then moving onwards
if it's still wild then
you go through that jesus christ sorry
guys
do you guys do you guys ask girls that
you're seeing like about what they've
done before or do you just you're like
see no either evil hear no evil like i
don't want to know really i think i
think when you're when you're going to
speak to a girl
someone knows something i mean so you
don't really even have to ask directly
you can kind of get
a sense of who someone is
about the way they speak and where they
talk and the way their friends speak
about them and stuff like that yeah they
don't really have to choose them
directly
to kind of gauge what's going on more
time they can lie as well yeah they can
actually live maybe not would you know
if they're lying
right you'll never you would never you
never know exactly if i tell you like
you can't argue with me like a lot of
girls know every single person a lot of
girls will say that pc is one it's
really 20.
[Music]
because they know that because they know
but that's actually some girls some
girls would like saying that the bc is
one and if you're oh that's calm you get
to know her and then she didn't realize
she's putting all the tricks out of the
bag that's right not even just that like
sometimes like even your boys because
even your boys would be like no
she's active bro like what are you doing
like oh no bc is one huh he told you
that and then that's when assuming that
problems can start in it because like
they know that the type of guy you are
you're not going to deal with a girl
that's like out there so they're going
to have to lie to you but you that's
something you never know mm-hmm so
she yeah you should be open from the
start but i guess you can't avoid in
certain situations mm-hmm
but okay so
bc is one thing right
like like a girl what she's done but i
think it takes it to another level when
it's on the internet like i have
brothers i would never tell them to deal
with a girl that has any sort of only
fans any sort of sex tape on the
internet like ever
because like your kids are going to see
that one day
and like that's what you're seeing now
with kim kardashian like look at the
like that she has to have that
conversation with all four of her kids
so can you imagine having a mom with an
off like only fans
[Music]
[Music]
no but like if
no but if we're talking about like kim k
of course like
her sex tape is gonna gonna be out there
because she's really like up there but
if we're talking about like a normal
person
i think it's gonna go away you're not
gonna like find a video like of someone
that you don't really know about
mm-hmm i think things definitely like
brush over like i think think about
coming along i think about school that
time stuff gets sent around inside now
do you remember that no look look at ash
cash bro now
because of what she's done exactly but
like not everyone's going to be popping
like that's right
like that i mean right
now if she's
[Music]
i think there's exceptions to every rule
right but it's still like in general
like i just don't know why as a guy
you'd want to deal with that do you
think that guys put up with like bad
behavior because a chick is like really
good looking some people do yeah i think
it's more easier to look over yeah you
know like let's say like you bagged
let's say you've been
let's say you've had one lengthening now
and it's like the girls toxic but
because she's lengthy you know like if
you have her by your side i'm animal
like yeah i rate your thing so when you
go behind closed doors she might be so
toxic like bro like no one's meant to be
going through that but because she's
laying that issue that's what you're
like you're putting up with it because
you just want to keep her there you get
it
so yeah
i think a lot of guys care about like
other like guys validating them that's
why they put up with it
and that's how we'll stem from but even
now like girls of bad behavior like all
that toxic [ __ ] like it's normalized now
so
a lot of guys tend to look for that now
it's just crazy
yeah some guys like it man
i have been saying that every show that
i think there's a type of guy that likes
girls that are a little bit mean to them
yeah they're i mean and keep them keen
like no but i don't like dad next
question next question no like no well i
just like will smith okay take well
smith no no let's just use him as an
example okay
you cannot you can
you can't you cannot tell me that will
smith did not have the option to pick a
girl that was nice to him when he was on
the fresh prince of freaking bel-air
he could have had his pick of what like
lined up
and he picked the one girl
that like is borderline and like abusive
to him mentally she was in love with
tupac yeah she was in love with someone
else well you're shown like at the
beginning because like what you're shown
like what someone decides to show you
could be completely different than what
they really are do i mean it's like
years down the line it could be tomorrow
but it could be years down she was like
crying on their wedding day what do you
mean
so look how long they would have been
for and obviously there's signs and
stuff but like yeah if you like it you
like it
yeah
now will smith went up on the stage i
actually smacked someone for her and she
said that she still did all that with a
madness like that's crazy i could never
have a goal that like i'd do with that
for my man just missing no yes mama made
a joke about your your your head
[Music]
no no but no but keep it cool that's one
thing another guy went into your wife
you could even knock him down to do
nothing like i can't let your waist man
no
be
no
real will smith i love french version of
lebron like that's my guy but after i
saw that and i saw everything
i'm not gonna lie
to that you're not gonna go for the guy
bro why are you gonna go for the guy
first her bro but that's what i'm saying
if you're not gonna go for the guy that
went into your wife don't go for no one
that chats about your wife bro yeah
i think there's there's levels in it
you sat right there
he was set right there
with your wife bro and someone said you
know it's a bit more than just like yeah
there's a bit more in the marriage you
still let bro you bro your wife told you
in your face on flipping the whole world
knew it bro
you bro i i trucked another guy because
what i needed some sort of security yeah
but whether he
that's different what i'm saying to you
is let's say you're sitting there with
your wife right now and i make a joke a
personal joke but to you to me that's
what chris is meant to do
yeah he literally is on the show to
present that's jokes
that's his job so if you take it how you
take it he literally does that for a
living
everyone has to know this was right i'm
just saying yeah in terms of like
defending her or going to suffolk
in that moment
she's going through this this and that
you're the other chris christopher it's
just a joke i mean
that's what you did today but how was
how was how's chris rock supposed to
know she had alopecia he doesn't care
he just wants your phone he handed it
differently but even if you mess with
him
by not slapping a grown man on this like
because
when he grabbed his oscar whatever it is
tell everyone that look that was not
okay mm-hmm like in front of everyone
that he could have
but like
he was just acting up acting our
character like yo yeah you just trying
to pull the point
in the moment and you think after you
think of raw like maybe a bit too much
do you i'm saying but it happens bro
yeah no
but like maybe if you're like
you know 18 but
i'm sorry if like a grown ass man you
don't you're not in control enough of
your emotions tonight that's what i'm
trying to say because it was in front of
them nice it's hard
it's hard that was a big audience
yes so then so then so then grow a pair
and leave don't you don't have to like
you don't have to put up with that
and like like imagine imagine okay if
jada was a dude okay and and or let's
say will smith did it he hooks up with a
20 year old
that is addicted to drugs that they took
in from the time he was like 15. she was
like 15. and then he sleeps with her
all right
like you don't you do you think the
world would have like
no he would be done yeah and it's such a
double standard
yeah
and it's like like she's almost i would
say predatory to be honest and
entanglement she said an entanglement
that would
she give it a whole different meaning
honestly i'm gonna read super chats
really quick y'all you guys are blowing
this up okay
um okay eat godly finally we get some
exposure on this channel thank you chris
n a hundred dollar super chat thank you
so
much you
that's good that's what i wanted to do
um okay okay and we almost have we
almost have 100 people watching right
now so make sure you like the video to
get
get the numbers up okay
um okay so would you chris ann would you
rather fight a hundred duck-sized horses
or one horse-sized duck please use it
please use real life
you know what a hundred dollars all
right let's do it
um personally i would rather fight
a hundred duck-sized horses or one i
would do one horse-sized dog because i
just feel like i would lose track
no
yeah but a hundred is so much
there's a hundred of them if you defeat
five they're still 95 you have to defeat
you're not gonna have the capacity
like if i could just figure out how to
kill the one it'd just be easier than a
hundred yeah exactly
um okay
um okay ten dollars from disrespectfully
cassie mark e blassy pearl you look
great today i hope you move back to the
u.s you're a catch thank you um okay
five dollars
hi from croatia thank you so much jada
pinkett
talk smack
jada pinkett two dollars talk smack now
that i'm in the room pearly i will
you're wilding get out of these streets
okay um so i have a question for the
ladies she looked directly at me
do you think that
who gets wifed up faster hoes or proots
wait explain
like a girl a girl that like waits or a
girl that sleeps with a guy right away
whoa who do you think it gets wifed up
faster
it really is a sticky one that's a good
question
someone that get um
a food someone that awaits you think so
yeah i believe so because i feel like if
you're able
kind of does depend on the vibe but if
you're able to just like
slang it out so soon so quickly he might
not take you as seriously as someone
that's like more patient and would get
to know him
and kind of understanding better really
yeah let's hear from the guys i disagree
totally okay yeah you'd rather have
someone that would just no no
you don't have to slang it out no but
that was but no but it's like
there's a difference between that let's
say you make someone wait for a month
but whilst you're making me wait for a
month let's say i may just like lose
interest but you're making moves towards
like but she's just holding off i'm just
saying that
not me but just like people
people they might like
lose interest in that because is that
all that like chasing and stuff like
that bro not everyone wants to do the
chasing stuff for so long but i mean you
can you chase say you chase you get it
what now imagine you chase for imagine
you chased for a month and it's dead bro
okay and then what if you chase for a
month and it's good then you're chilling
but we could have been good
the next day
all right um maybe we're not you know
personally this is what 29 days so it's
basically it's based on the 90-day rule
i don't know that's a bit of a sticky
one see because
on one hand i feel like guys do value
some sort of purity right and it's
biologically wired so they can't really
get rid of it but any guy like that
finds out his girl slept with a hundred
people probably wants to throw up
yeah yeah
okay i'll get a heart you know
it has to you have to you know i mean
run a little bit and
you know flex a little bit but you can't
just you know because then you think our
next man could have had it easy like
that yeah so
it's just i guess there is a balance in
it because then you could go on a lit
first date and you guys could have sex
and then it could even be even better
but because you know the person you guys
are on the same vibe you kind of can
move forward from that but whereas like
do you know what i mean slang it out and
then you're done with that
yeah i feel like i feel like there is a
balance like
wait but don't slang out too early to
get yeah but if you're gonna make them
wait don't make them wait too long that
just depends on who the guy is there's
some guys that don't mind they can wait
till marriage some guys
yeah
[Laughter]
no but there are actually some guys that
can't wait would want to wait but that
just depends on them yeah well that's
the thing that just has to be
i feel like that just has to be a
balance between it
are you waiting until you're married
okay
i thought you you said you said okay
she said
someone in the comments that says it's
not biologically wired it is
biologically wired because over in
history men have to ensure paternity
so and the reason men prefer like a
lower body count is because historically
they had to ensure paternity
so um they had to make sure that they
weren't passing on resources to a kid
that wasn't theirs
because birth control changed the game
but that wasn't around historically and
even now there's some studies that say
up to like 20 percent of men are raising
a kid that's not theirs
it's crazy so would you guys do that
he's a kid that's not mine yeah
you'll fall in love with it yeah that's
hard
[Music]
[Laughter]
about it think about it so so she told
you she's pregnant like two months
pregnant
so for that seven months before the
baby's born you've
grown to like adapt to like becoming a
man and then
you could be with a kid like four months
five months could be the first day you
love that baby
like find out that's not yours
your love for the baby is not gonna like
change it's gonna change for the girl
you're gonna hate the girl yeah
resentment every time you look at the
baby you could just be like damn
like i can't control it have you not
seen them them like judge shows where
they're having like them like they have
the test or you're the father you're not
the father
and you see that like that the men just
break down in tears
but if she's had the kid already and
would you guys do it then
you have to collect for the ride i mean
for the right the kid has to be young
though if you're
15. oh my gosh
you know you know what's crazy about
that like
the perception will probably change like
you know if you're like 40 50 unless
you're single
bro a lot of women that you're gonna
come
in contact with may have a kid bro
they're going to be 15 16 17 18
then it will change bro i mean yeah when
i get to that point it would change 15
hours loose bro we're like 20.
come on imagine i'm trying to imagine
i'm trying to say something you're not
my dad oh
no but it's like when they're younger
yeah it'll be less it'll be a less
likely thing that they will say that
because yeah because they're young in it
that's probably
the first exactly
but they know that there's a day now
someone's coming to now come like take
over
and then you've raised your voice at me
like are you my dad like you are you bro
i can't like that [ __ ] will burn bro
so wait would you guys date a single mom
so you you sounds like you wouldn't
whoa
i would do that hold on don't do that
i would
it depends though i probably would
really
like two months talking like intense
talking like i'm saying like your
combo every day but okay you guys like
are you are you that desperate
like you could date a girl without kids
why on earth would you date a girl with
a kid actually
because because that's that one you're
raising you're putting your time
attention and resources into another
man's kid and she could break it off
with you tomorrow you put all this time
attention and resources and raising
someone else's kid you get nothing you
have no right all the resources
i mean
yeah it's just i mean i'm not paying
child support
if you live life like that you're not
going to do anything yeah because you
can say that about the girl as a single
like i mean she doesn't have a kid as
well you put all your time and results
into that girl for her to bend you off
and cut yeah
child don't know a child
you get married with no kids
yeah like i would oh my gosh i have
brothers if they brought home a girl
with a kid i would tell them to dump her
immediately
if if off the rip you told me you have a
kid baby daddy
like yeah that's madness
but that's what people tend to do you
know they don't they don't they don't
let you know a few things and then after
a bit when you feel like yeah it'd be a
lot harder to just leave by the way i've
got a baby dad
already
it's gonna be harder but like at the
start you shine and there's a lot of
people that do it think about how many
stories are on people that like bring up
kids that's not even theirs bro and they
have a happy family
come on man obviously there's some that
don't yeah but that's with everything
but like why would you want to like take
that extra baggage like that's just
baggage because you have to deal with
the axe yeah you don't look at baggage
if the girls just got like i mean i feel
like if the girl just got it then she's
got it like you know what's interesting
when i'm like talking to a guy and he
tells me he would date a single mom i
like like him less
because i'm like like to me your
discernment is off oh what do you think
that they're just picking
more well it's like it's like why would
you if like it's like almost desperate
and i'm not trying to be mean so sorry
but like but like because i'm like do
you not have any other like are you that
desperate you would date a single mom
does that show you desperation
because you could like because it's like
you act like there's even if you're
talking to a girl for a month it's only
been a month that's better than raising
someone else's kid for the rest of your
life
and it's one thing like happiness like
i think kids with people with kids
should date each other
i didn't i've been in a situation where
dude didn't tell me he had kids i was
out cooked no next
year
yeah
can we keep dating no and he was he was
rich too like i could have like been
taking care nope
nasty cook and i'm and i'm a girl like
so and i feel like as a guy it's like
worse
yeah but why wouldn't just the vibe was
just right like just you're letting the
kid get in the way of like your
happiness but building building a family
isn't about vibes like it's not about
good vibes and happiness like that's why
that's why marriage is crumbled today
because it's not based on logic it's
based on what feels good in the moment
like oh my goodness
nice like i get it if you want a girl
for the night fine or like a date for a
couple months but i just i feel like men
should have standards and it's really
sad because nowadays like
like no honestly men should have
standards and nowadays like they're
ashamed and to have like not like people
yeah
that's very nice do you guys feel like
you have standards
yes
absolutely
100 adam
[Music]
okay i'm gonna read super chats for a
second okay grimlock um why is the girl
in the middle being more real than the
bro stop self-filtering
um chris
um chris chris n stop the cat the horse
the horse-sized duck would f you up one
quack would make you death
um the correct answer would be i would
call a man to come save me from the
ducks because i'm weaker than a man
peter b discipline and direction
grimlock trapper a super samp um okay
what you're trying to say
it's your head
it's a head
super scent for sure it's your head
who's shopper oh it must be mom
but it
might be really still
like your eyes are just here
wait i don't think they can see the hat
like that wait let me show you oh they
can they can they're going to therefore
yeah
that's a new job so of course
[Music]
trap staff
well god theirs
[Music]
okay how
would you tell
your kid that your wife has an only fan
help
that's not
from the guys that said yes when i said
that you would date someone that had
something on the internet i wouldn't
that conversation is between
the wife and the kids
that's that conversation between the
wife and the kid no but if you had to
say it don't let if you actually i
wasn't already friends yeah but how
would you explain that
yeah like like no no no no imagine ask
your mom
mom
that's not my
you're not african you wouldn't know
okay would you guys rather have a girl
that was a nine and looks like one of
the baddest chicks you've ever seen in
your life okay
but
but she's got an only fans or a girl
that's like a six
what are we doing on this only
that's the thing
could be toes
bikinis they have to be specific
okay no let's say let's say it's like
she's not sleeping with anyone else but
it's sexual content what like is she in
a like any type of state or is she naked
yeah everyone likes
to take the sex if she if she wears like
a balaclava or something
but the name was still give it away
though
like long term now this is long term
long term yeah six is coming my way yes
six years
i won't be no six is like
peace i ain't ever getting married first
unit but a six is like a six is like one
above me bro it's one of them
that means you can you can probably deal
with it
she has time to grow up no but it's not
true
that's that's wrong the nine's gonna
come away
adam was the nine
man
i can't do it it's just like it's not
how do you take him out to your mom
respect that i just think with the
family
you're taking that to your mom yeah
well i hide so fast away from one minute
like your mum might not need to know
that's what i'm saying like that but you
know parents you know when you get to
know someone they want to know
everything about it
do you know what it is your little
sister could even find it mom look at
her very long dude
i'm the only child
you even have to go to the internet
you're playing the game minding your
business
online bro
all it takes is
you're done well my mom was minding his
business bro
it was a peaceful day like you guys
realize looks fade
depends i mean in secondary
looks could could get better though i
know some people that have glowed up and
look amazing i think that's like a lie
that girls tell each other
i don't know
some guys are really good now like
i think some girls glow up maybe like on
instagram but like in person you still
see like can you can you can see girls
filters they just got better doing
makeup yeah
it becomes a casual like there isn't
this and the angles are not bro
like you know if you survey men from
like 20 to 80 years old you know what
age they find the most attractive 20.
i'm saying 25 to 30. i'm going to say
20.
it's like 20. it's like 23 24. yeah it's
like it's like um i think it's 22-23
so you you get like some girls that
maybe get some work done but i just
think like i don't know in person like
their face looks weird to me a lot of
the time
yeah like that like the the botox eyes
like the
the non-facial expressions yeah yeah
you know when they can't they can't move
their face properly oh you're struggling
what qualities do you guys look for in a
wife like a
or a long-term girlfriend you guys are
young oh god oh adam what
that's a draw out
but like if that situation already
consider it in the future it depends on
what the relationship i'll have with a
goal but of course you shouldn't don't
do that
but it's my life maybe you can but i
just think it's not wise
who determines
it's not people's opinions it can be
backed up by data but you have to get
freedom you you have to live care i mean
i think that's fine if you want to live
carefree but i don't think that results
in long happy marriages
i know
like do you think that's conducive for
building families
it can work i've seen i've seen that
i've seen it within my family i think it
depends on upbringing too
like you have to be able to be like
exposed to co-parenting and seeing
broken families to know what works for
you and what doesn't work for you
depends on how open you are yeah
okay if you're if you're quite
close-minded to certain things and
you're not really gonna
one go 100 in for something so then
there's no point dude no i just got to
make sure the kids are right in it
so
so so let's say you marry you marry a
single mom okay
you date her for 10 years okay do you
guys break up
why
so why
because that happens it's like the
average after you get married no after
you get married the average like um age
of divorce or the average time it takes
to get divorced is like eight years so
let's say you get there when it's like
the kids one you leave when it's nine
you have no rights to that child
none
but that's your child though no i know
but you like like i've heard horror
stories of men that like they raised
these children and then it doesn't work
out with the mom she doesn't want
anything to do with him now they have no
rights to that kid that's what i mean
when i say it's not wise
yeah that's a very difficult
that's just a risk you take i don't
think anyone's going to go into a
situation thinking this isn't going to
work in 10 years so then what happens if
this right but there's but there's
things you can do to lower your your
risk take risk and prosper i think like
but why
well why do it when you don't have to oh
because let's be real you don't know
what the future is going to bring so
when you're in the moment you're
thinking yeah everything's going to be
all right everything's going to be good
and then the future comes and then it
doesn't go to plan there's a lot of
instances where that is your child and
10 years down the line it doesn't work
whatever now mum's got full custody you
know you're in square one with the other
guy that's not even his child as well so
a lot of things it it's not as plain and
simple just saying
let's limp like let's limit the risk
like it's not as easy because there's
still times where you can limit risk but
then
it still happens you get so
not everything is in your control
sometimes because anything can happen
that's what i do well but but that but
that that is in your control who you
date
that's like the number one like yeah it
is
no but it's drinking control of like the
situation that happens yeah in 10 years
let's say you break up like you can't
control that because you can't see
yourself from now in 10 years divorcing
the girl because in that moment you're
thinking yeah this is someone i'm gonna
be for the rest of my life and then as
the 10 years is creeping up
things are just going left like there's
no point already preparing for exactly
like and it's like you're trying to fix
it but maybe it's not fixable and then
you just get to that 10 year mark and
then boom like
you can have you can have your own
family
break up with your mom after 10 years
and then obviously like the kid might
not want to talk to you or anything even
though it's your kid the kid might not
want to talk to you but you still have
rights in court yeah he's not it's
definitely not favored towards men
that's true you have rights in court but
you would know if the kid wants to be of
you or not because there's so many kids
that say no i don't want to go to my
dad's house like no like please don't
make me go there even like really i know
a lot of crazy moms yeah
it's true but it's like after that after
you've gone through that you're telling
me you wouldn't date another single
woman i mean a single mom
makes no difference it's no difference
really it's just wow this is really
interesting this is the first group of
guys that i've ever had on here that's
like yeah i would date a single mom
there's nothing really wrong
for me personally i would date one
whether i'm gonna go to marry the dirt i
don't know yeah we don't know exactly
but to date one just off the rip date
come on bro um
would you would you want your brothers
to date a single mom would you have no
do you have brothers no no you have no
brothers
all sisters oh yeah but i mean what
about the close close male friend yeah
wood
so i just i think it's it's baby mama
drama that i don't like that's right
that's what i like it if your baby
mama's giving drama
look it off what what is drama though
what like what do you mean
just like oh why are you out with her
your kids
well because girls girls are at least a
hormone during sex or no so during sex
and when they have a kid so when you
have a kid with someone you like release
a hormone that makes you like bond with
them right so
you're very much attached to someone you
have a child with gosh
you're learning a lot today
and you know what else is interesting
like man
yeah let's continue men release a
hormone during sex that makes them like
territorial over a girl yeah that
they've slept with that's why i've heard
guys like say like they'll sleep with a
girl and they like don't want to date
her or care about her but they still
like don't like her
like moving on because they're like
territorial
you guys just feel like yo she can't do
nothing
it's just it's yours it's mine
but is it a thing where you don't want
to cover
but it's yours
for some guys like you've had your fun
of her you want to go do your thing but
you don't want to see her move on oh
yeah [ __ ]
she go nowhere
this is how you get like girls like
fighting each other over a guy you know
i don't think i could ever do something
like that like fight over a guy yeah i
just feel like if you have that other
option bro that
that's yours
no i wouldn't either
like let him go yeah it's not worth the
fight
no not but i feel like that's why
because it got
focused
don't try it just no
okay um
i'm gonna read some more super chats um
can you close that door just so
my dog's gonna park
um
okay so i just got another super chat
guys like the video
like it okay if you guys like the
content you want to keep um seeing it
like the video also
all super chats are going towards a new
camera so i'd really like to get
two or three camera angles in here so
you can like see people more when they
talk
oh
yeah i want to invest in new lights too
so i don't even keep the money
um i have some complaints today
i don't even keep the money that you
guys send me at this point like i
literally reinvest all of it into the
equipment and building a better show for
you guys so every super chat really
really helps build the show and i really
appreciate it so
um the next super chat let's see
um is
grimlock xo pearl is the female kevin
samuels handing out these elves
okay
um
do you would you guys date a girl that's
like overweight
no no
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'll put it i
apologize um he's good he must be
apologizing
yeah no no respectfully in it but
if she's oversized like she's over it
depends what you mean by overweight
personal to your size though yeah 100 so
if she if she's like if she's you know
obviously
yeah if she's ob yeah i wouldn't even
look in that direction
i think about i'll be thinking about
ways around it like
[Laughter]
oh athletes yes i'm just kidding i can't
handle that bro
it's about what you can handle don't
know
if you could handle you know what i'm
saying
as much as they're eating
would you date a guy that's shorter than
you
no she wouldn't
[Laughter]
i mean like if i'm i'm seeing you guys i
mean i can live with that bar hills
shorter than me hills no thank you i
want you to be able to help me how tall
is the top shelf
5'4
i want you to be able to help me like
why am i understood and you were trying
to get us to as well
[Music]
okay they're helping each other
that can help me around you know what i
mean you know you know what's
interesting men are ashamed for not
dating overweight women but women will
say all day like oh he needs to make
this much money he used to be this tall
that i don't know i'll just let someone
let's not get started
let's listen let's not get started let's
hear it but let's let's not know him
doesn't pay the bills though
i'll just say hey doesn't pay
yeah it doesn't i mean instagram if you
have a lot of followers it does pay the
bills but vbr doesn't like
do you know anyways next question
a bbl would you guys rather have a girl
with a smaller butt that's natural
natural or a bbl 110 natural natural
natural natural because if we're growing
older now i see your your things just
melting
why just why
nah man
so why is he dripping like no way like
bro you know like girls now that you be
bills you know how much you have to go
to gym and how much you have to get
checkups bro when you're 65 you're still
going to get checkups bro come on bro
how do you how do you know i didn't even
know this
yeah yeah more than like 5.99 no not bbc
there was a female that was a youtuber
and obviously naturally she kind of had
bunda
yeah but then
she then got used her fat from her
stomach into her
what is that the liposuction yeah but
then she then got a bbo and then she
became botched but it was like
she has to go with gymnastics to
maintain it and she goes through all
these healthy conditions and that
because of it and it's like when like
obviously you had a few roles in there
but it's like you could have still went
gym now you have to go to jail because
you have no choice because if you don't
encourage him you're going to die what
about like what about like what about
like fake boobs is it the same
it is the same
there's a very big difference between
what you actually want and what you like
to see yeah i mean
like obviously big breasts whatever
whatever i like when you see it on the
road on the street
yeah you might bro
it's a brother it's a brother that's
holding it in place like that
you know
whatever you like yeah cool but you
don't actually want that i mean like
when i'm at home i don't want this
you're blowing up in your face i don't
need that i don't want that you would
want canyon
so it depends it's a lot of what you
need versus what you just like to look
at social media change like the
perspective of what some men
looking
for girls these days i think
yeah true i think it's because we're
coming into a digital age now where a
lot of things on social media are
actually affecting lives like it's
true and all that yeah especially since
clover because everyone just shifted
online
because no one was outside everyone was
like one line like do you know what i
mean
anyone remember that phase that everyone
became youtubers
do you guys think that social media um
gave unrealistic standards more for men
or for
women and men men men
would you have to be a boss
yeah you have to make money in like all
that yeah definitely men like sometimes
it's like oh when you get into our
argument
and he doesn't send you like 300 pounds
and he's not the one like what
and the thing is girls actually start
believing that
i actually stopped believing that like
no no we just argued
of course we would we know you we know
do you do you feel like most girls think
they're hotter than they are 100 110 yes
yeah but they say no girls are bad you
know your friend is media you guessed
him as soon as you let's get into an
argument or a fight you are ugly anyways
like bro
no but like
i don't know it's not in terms of like
reassurance because some girls don't
need that but if guys aren't
giving them the kind of look you know i
mean it it kind of does boost a bit of
confidence
you're not going to marry a godo you
don't know that well but
we lie to each other though like i've
been to a point where i was i would say
like i was overweight right because
after college um i stopped playing
sports and it just caught up to me like
really fast and i ended up losing it but
like oh my god my friends have gassed me
up so much and i'd be like no i'm fat oh
they'll be like you're fake yeah
like there'll be times that a guy could
get a trim like i could get a trim that
was the time i got a trim i was feeling
it
my boy sorry you know
what the [ __ ] is that who's who's nicer
you know what i mean what's kinder to
someone telling them the truth or
telling them what they want to hear
i think it depends on your relationship
as well
it's my friend from a distance i'm gonna
tell you look good you know but if it's
my friend friend i'm gonna take [ __ ] up
like that that dress let's pick a
different one still i feel like i fall
out for guys
i feel like for guys guys can take more
criticism than girls yeah yeah they just
burn in silence yeah yeah i got a guy it
would burn the guy but they gotta move
on but if the girl now gets burned yeah
it's like what so what you're better
than me now it still depends on the
friendship though
yeah but even some friendships some
girls can be friends for years and like
sometimes some girls they're just girls
they're just girls that just can't take
criticism so no matter how long you're
friends with someone yeah they were just
doing just still that it's still going
to be something that they're going to
keep inside and just wait to just
like just without writing them just
attack
yeah yeah you get it
okay so i'm gonna read the super chats
real quick guys
164 live viewers in here this is the
most viewers i've ever had on a show
hey because of me
this is great guys um don't forget to
like the video leave a comment in the
chat if you guys have any questions that
you want me to read sometimes i like
scroll through just to see if i see any
interesting ones
um while you're at it any super chats
i'm gonna read so don't forget and don't
forget about our sponsor tonight if you
want a customized meal plan specifically
for you okay
all you do is you tell the guy what
foods you already like to eat and he
gives you a customized meal plan with
the nutrients you're supposed to eat
every single day guys i can attest i've
lost like 20 pounds on this meal plan
like it's so good and and you like the
food that you're eating that's what
makes it special okay
um super chats let's see
um
we got two more
um fran to see
if a man raises a child that he believes
is hid and the mother knows that she
lied should she be punishable by law and
what would the punishment be she should
be punished
she should be less likely
you you wasted that man's time for help
and you knew what you was doing as well
you knew what you was doing yeah and i i
would i would even argue however many
years the guy spent like raising that
kid give her a gift
that's that's it's terrible that's a
terrible thing to do you deserve to be
punished you wasted that man you know
how much do you know how much like
emotion yeah he's pointing into that kid
that's something like that
stop you from even having your own yeah
i mean yeah
yeah
to be honest i think it's just the same
as like females lying about uh rape it's
the exact same for me to be honest you
should say great say great youtube
great great great great saying so great
i like such a sensitive subject though
like yes yeah it's exactly the same it's
all the same right category because it
actually happens and then that people
lie so it's like when it comes up
people don't don't know whether to like
how to attach it yeah it's always
detrimental to someone's image because
it's true imagine i said on your name
like
your life changes literally like bro it
happened i don't know
you don't have to say names i'm not
gonna say names but obviously okay it
happened last year in it but the one
thing about me is i'm not i'm not i'm
not a biased guy like i always want to
hear two sides of the story long story
short
i didn't sign no one but i was still
there for the guy so if i found out it
was true i'd be like oh cool i'm gonna
have to back up but everyone else is
like oh rah-rah long story short that
the guy didn't do it so this girl got
everyone against him now everyone was
just there like he boss case he's
chilling but it's like yeah the fact
that that whole time period bro yeah bro
the guy was in his room like
upset sad like he had no one bro i'm
better man he was the one that
introduced me to everyone so everyone
just left him i was just thinking
it's one of the dumb ones like if you if
you play sports
how could you even leave your room to
even come yeah if that on your name like
everyone's gonna be looking at you
differently if you have a game they're
gonna be like oh yeah that's the guy
how's he even allowed to play
that like this is what's up right now
it's not true and they even might look
at you differently as well it's just
change your whole character literally
and that's the thing like girls even if
they don't go to the police they can
still spread that rumor around campus
yes and girls don't really question each
other on it
yeah like like if if your friend came to
you like i'm not gonna be like oh was it
true like how'd that happen
so it's kind of like i just believe it
straight away yeah literally
no i i don't always believe it but but
i'm not gonna say it like but i'm not
going to say anything because like what
if it did happen that's that's the
problem
i think it's a thin line between like
supporting your friend but you still
have to operate on that facts do you i
mean because you need to ask questions
to know like if you know what it is
it's you're not going to question her
emotions so if if like
a female went to another female she was
very emotional about that that topic
you're not even going to think twice
about questioning it and obviously going
to pay in the back of your mind like did
it actually happen but
your first reaction would be like oh
yeah like i'm gonna just cater to you
like
you can be with me like whatever you
need i've got you do you think that dna
test should be mandatory i think yes yes
yes yes save a lot of time yes
because boy
hundred percent
i feel like it gets to the point as well
i feel like if it was a lot of a lot of
time wasting that goes on would be quite
short like literally
yeah for real
because then you get to know sure
it doesn't even have to be mandatory but
i think because a lot of people like
they're so confident or maybe they just
they just don't want to know do you guys
mean but like
even if you're just
it's an option at the end of breakfast
like would you do when you if one of
them say yes you have to do it do you i
mean it's not like oh cause i said no
like we don't have to do it like what
are you talking about but how does that
work with celebrities though so for
example like no but for example
drake mentioned in one of his songs that
one wanted some random girl just said oh
let me get a pregnancy test and you're
just wasting the guy's time because
multiple goals would you do the same
thing over and over again trying to
make time and crowd from him so it has
to be certain goals that
that that has to be a limit
on the way you do that
to protect certain individuals from
wasting weight
that's true
over and over and over again just ask
your friend
sorry but i don't i don't know you know
why am i getting pregnant for me i think
it's a thing where if you're a celebrity
and you know the status you hold and
everything that comes with it
first of all you should be careful
anyway
like whether you chose to become a
celebrity or not like i mean
and to it to me it doesn't whether
you're celebrity or not you're just like
everyone else so if it's mandatory it's
mandatory bro yeah you're still going to
have another day because you're
celebrating because you gotta get on
this flight at this time and do this
this and that you should have thought
about that before messing about you're
that's
gonna
say
life holds bro it's like for us bro
we're athletes we play basketball you're
not going to do anything
out of that line because you know what
you need to do yeah i'm saying so now if
you're messing about and stuff and now
people are telling you to do this test
and do that yeah you've got to do it bro
whether you whether you're athlete not
actually a celebrity or not bro you have
to do it
yeah i guess so because it it may waste
time but at least you're certain and you
know yeah
knowing that this is 100
then oh just skip it and now i don't
know what sport but what if you've never
met the girl before and she just made it
up then then obviously like people you
look into stuff like that and it's like
bro like i don't even know who you are
yeah i'm saying that that's
yeah dna tests have to be done still no
it's kind of hard to do to know like if
you have
a kid or responsibility out there and if
you're able to actually cater to that if
you can't and you don't know then that
just makes your life 10 times harder
because you're thinking about that every
day we're talking about the story bro
sorry
if it's mandatory turn the girl's going
to waste their time literally they're
just wasting her their own time because
if she knows that raw at the end of this
or at some point we need to do the test
and this is not true yeah they're not
going to pick on drake all of a sudden
out of the blue just to say
and we've never even seen each other in
person in our lives because now when it
gets to it
she just found out how deep is it what's
the point of that it was the sun goes on
the cloud though like people will talk
about for example that some girls ask
you for a pregnancy test
and like they'll get like a little
publicity and some go just like demons
like that so it's like that's that but
that's the thing though um obviously
there was a time where like there was a
time where i think i don't i think it
was all dirk apparently oh she was
messing around with someone else and
then there was a kid that looked exactly
like little dirk it's a thing where we
don't know what's going on what they do
so because things that get publicized
here like gets baited out it's just
straight that's just cloud like stuff
like that just clap because maybe yeah
he did have a kid back then and
the baby mum and dad already know
because you don't know nothing people
want clout now all of a sudden he's
jumping on 2022 you're saying that oh
yeah little dirk has a new kid and she's
he's cheating on india
come on bro like that's just time
wasting did you get
like but people want to just
see people fail and stuff like that
that's what i'm saying like you have a
name for yourself and everyone's like oh
really
you know what i mean oh 10 years ago you
did this to me
it's just long like why why would you
want to do that to someone yeah people
don't want to see like you don't want to
honestly and it's sad though don't you
think yeah it's just a while ago
because everybody just wants
certain things and some people want what
they can't have so they'll do anything
in their power to tear that down and it
makes no sense because there's no like
there's no glory at the end of the day
for you well the crazy thing is like
you could give people an instruction
guide on how to like no you could give
them an instruction guide on how to like
accomplish what you've accomplished they
won't do it 90 of the time it's true
like
in fact they'll probably be even more
pissed off that you gave it to them and
just be like well i don't need that i
don't need your help
people just
have you guys heard do you remember what
happened to drake a little bit back with
the um
i forgot what he the hot sauce
oh he put horses in a condom yeah
[Music]
and then the girl i went in the bathroom
after and tried to obviously obviously
like finish whatever i put in her
because he should have a baby or try and
conceive obviously those hot sauces
he's the goat
he is the goat that's smart that's good
that just shows that just shows you how
touched
do you think that should be illegal for
girls to do that to take yes
not conceive and then you're gonna go
now and then you do this
if i give you that one elbow can i you
can't now
bro
i wouldn't do that by the way
like we hear you hear you
it was kind of crazy because like it
kind of makes you think how
how long has that been going on like how
many kids have been conceived out of
like stealing uh
like
and that's so selfish too because
because you're bringing a kid into the
world that like the dad doesn't even
want he probably wants nothing to do
with you if you have to steal it
like someone will be making a joke and
like oh yeah i was a mistake and i'm
like
like
like deeper like you the kid came into
the audio and he's actually realized
that now you're like that's something he
has to mentally deal with you or she has
to deal with like ra no i was a mistake
all right like because my mom didn't
want my husband um my dad to leave or
something like that
she did what she did just so she could
have a kid like bro
that's a human bro like you don't play
you don't play like that
yeah just stick you on still
uh
so i saw something really interesting
this week on twitter
um and it was a screenshot of a text
that this girl got from her dad after
being on only fans
oh no jesus i'm gonna i'm gonna read it
i'm gonna i'm gonna read it people
thought it was like my dad i was like no
no
no no no
um okay um i sit here missing you i feel
like i failed you in many ways
and for that i'm truly sorry sorry
whatever i did to you to make you feel
this way about yourself depresses me and
makes me wish that i could have raised
you differently and given you the
support you truly needed you are doing
things that make me ashamed what hurts
what hurts the most is the pain you are
causing mom and i doesn't bother you
i am not sure how to express it any
better but i can't support you in what
you're doing i don't know if you even
want a relationship with your family but
i can't be part of
part of one if you are going to
contribute continue this i have been a
very proud dad growing up dad up to this
point and now i'm having depression over
this
um
you live in a dream world your followers
are a bunch of horny scummy little
creeps you actually believe that you are
an influencer the next kardashian grow
the hell up you are just making a third
rate smut for creeps to look at and if
you think that little piece of [ __ ] you
are doing this with is loyal to you you
better think again he's laughing at you
behind your back to his low rent friends
get yourself tested once a week for
herpes and other stds would be the best
advice for you if i thought that you
were making an intelligent decision do
you think i would be angry at you
if if you thought that you were making a
good decision do you think you would be
trying to hide it to me hide it from me
i haven't threatened you but maybe that
scuzzy little boyfriend needs a visit
um and then she says do you don't want
me to be happy in the history of corn
most of the people that participate in
filming it end up in misery i'll start
sending you examples you are too young
and don't know enough to realize how the
world works to realize that why would
you possibly think i don't want you to
be happy you are just tired of working
and just want to earn yourself some easy
money you don't have enough self-respect
to get something better to do and get
money and you actually believe you are a
social media sensation when you finally
wake up from
this
from your new career choice you are
going to crash and burn
[Music]
the girl because she was saying like she
was trying to get sympathy for it you're
a clown she's stupid you're a clown you
know you're actually a clown
you know i saw on twitter the other day
as well
some girl her little brother plays um
football in america so american football
and
he gets slandered because his sister is
like famous and only fans and like he
can't even like go to games or anything
without anybody knowing so it's just
like
the impact
so you doing that impacts your whole
family's life so like he can't live a
goal normal day without someone saying
oh yeah so your daughter is still like
imagine going to your football game and
everyone knows who you are because your
sister is just only friends where's the
next time she's uploading nothing is
crazy
that is crazy well it's selfish because
it's it's when you start when you have a
family you start building a family it's
not about you anymore
and like you're you're putting if you
want to have a family and like kids
someday
like that's that's something they're
going to have to live with because of
your poor choice why is only fans a
thing then like why is it a thing
because girls like why is it really was
it even out
it wasn't even invented for
corn yeah that's that's that's what's
crazy boy
because honestly in my opinion whenever
girls see a way to make money fast oh
whenever whenever girls find a way to
make money like quick easy fast all they
have to do is take their clothes off
girls are gonna do it
wow
i think a lot of guys would too they
just don't have the choice
[Music]
hey take off your clothes and only off
and let me know how it goes please
creepy man this is like oh i'm gonna pay
for that i guess
man it's men as well i don't know why
men fun dislike these guys these girls
their toes bro they're so rich
you know why you know why though because
um one in three men under 30 is a virgin
what
one in three men three yeah
there's a lot of there's a lot of guys
that like you don't even see one in
freedom they're like invisible to us
like the guy that takes your order at
walgreens all right i don't you guys
don't have walgreens here but i don't
know taco bell
or
they're just uh
that duke is a virgin yeah
but if that's the case you might as well
just go like you must go amsterdam
if there was another guy here no how
many guys are there
well i think it's a little different
well i think it's a little different
because you're taking from a pool of
athletes oh yeah and on top of that you
guys are what basketball yeah i mean you
know how basketball teams yeah
what does that mean
we got clowns though work for the whole
team
wait for the whole
yeah yeah especially especially in like
college university
of course you have to be that guy where
you walk around like campus as well
knowing that you're a basketball and
everyone knows who you are cause they
come to their games just like oh my god
go dance that's him like and i'd be like
yo
i see where the cooling humans names are
and you wanna think running out yeah
but did you know another interesting
stat is if you ask 80 of women what they
look for in a guy they list 20 percent
of men so the reason that women hate men
is because we're sleeping with the same
ones
um
so like for example
whoa okay
so the
if you ask 80 of women
what they look for in a guy and you say
like what what do you want so what would
you they might say
you know this tall this much money this
this this and this
they will say
20 of men so if you ask 80 of women what
they want in a guy they list out 20 of
men
and so the reason that women hate men is
because they're sleeping with the same
ones like for example if you take dating
app data
women only swipe right like five percent
of the time and it's the same guys
we're men we're men where men swipe
right like around fifty percent
so again the reason that women so if you
not me they're not me
breaking your thumbs
so so the reason that women hate men is
because they're sleeping with the same
one so when you hear girls say things
like men are trash that's basically like
i i sleep with trash man i don't know i
don't think i've said that yet but all
women just hate behaving on men for just
no reason to hate on us yeah they do
well some girls just like to follow
trends they've never actually been of a
guy that's trash
well what do you guys think of the um
what i read do you think that's how you
would handle it if you had a daughter
what do you think i don't think i would
have handled it like that probably
wouldn't have gone that far in i would
have
what
i would have it's just the opinion i can
tell you for free it depends how old the
the female is my daughter is i feel like
18 19. i don't think i've ever that's
how she that's all she probably is
though yeah don't call that comic bro 18
when you're like when you when you've
graduated and you're living your own
life i can't lie i've
given you your training so once you're
in the outside world bro whatever you do
a highlight that's you know your white
rights are wrong i think i think you're
done training like being trained by your
parents when you hit like 16 anyway
because that's the age where you get
like so it ranges between like 16 and 19
so that's the age of five
but like 16 or 19 you're still like in
your pet like you still live with your
parents
you're a lot more outside though like
you're going to college or you're yeah
you've got money
but the thing is like i don't know okay
i don't know how to explain but it's
like 16 to like 18 20 or whatever yeah
like you still leave go outside and come
back home so everything you do
i think it depends a lot like for me 18
i was in southampton do you i mean i was
by myself so i don't have to come home
or go out and be like oh yeah i'm going
here oh i did it i'm going
there's a lot of people like that so
it's like
from i think dan's right bro like from
like 16 really when you start going
college and it's not just school and
back school back school back you start
building a bigger friendship group on
your outside all the time you go in
cinema you're doing this so you say
you're doing this but you're already
over here you know what i'm saying
you've got to think about how much time
you're with your parents compared to
everyone else yeah so like you could
leave your house at eight o'clock or
nine
and you could get home at eight o'clock
or nine
that means you only spend how many hours
of your parents mm-hmm so they don't
know so within them hours what you're
gonna do anyway is eat watch a bit of tv
and then go to sleep your parents what
you're doing outside your parents would
never know so you could like there's two
different personalities from being at
home and being outside so
yeah well i think but at the same time
it's your job as a parent no matter how
old they are to like direct your kids in
some way the best you can
that's what i think
my mom is actually like my best friend
yeah
i like don't have friends i just have my
parents
[Laughter]
um
okay listen the mics okay i had a
people were saying there's a little echo
but i i they say they're saying it
sounds better now okay
let me know in the chat i'm not even
sure how i would fix an echo but
um
let's see
they are trying thank you for the super
chat they are trying to make dna tests
mandatory in the us
okay guys um if you're watching guys
don't forget to subscribe okay hit that
notification bell that way you're gonna
be notified every time i'm live
like this video okay leave a comment
um and if you send super chats again it
helps
build the studio so again we're trying
to get more cameras i'm trying to hire
help so i have people like helping me
run this
so every super chat like helps so thank
you guys
um okay
let me
so why do you think
kanye would pick kim kardashian when he
has all these options like from a guy's
point of view
dude can date anyone
and you know what the funniest thing is
you know after they broke up he went for
a girl that looked exactly like her yeah
you like what you like
i supposed
identical yeah
obviously at different people yeah but
like if you just glimpse that you would
have thought that was kim kardashian
your type is your type so he has a type
yeah your type is your time i also feel
like he just did it just to get back at
him but the question is then why why
would he go for it to prove a point
though
he could literally have what he wants
and why would he go for kim kardashian
knowing that she had a sex tape
instead of just going for the girl that
just looks like her if that's his type
it has to be something i think that's
what we was talking about at the start
like bro you like what you like
so for some guys you like something
but if you hear something and it's kind
of like oh like you're not gonna go
there but for some guys you can hear
alcohol that's what she did
basically a kim kardashian look-alike
there's obviously going to be loads of
people that look
roughly similar to her
why do you not just go for that
already at the start
[Music]
yeah because i don't think really that
to me i don't think a rich person is
going to go with a poor person you know
what i'm saying
[Music]
aspects no it really depends
okay let's be real let's be rolling
i don't think drake's gonna date anyone
i think he's going to be in the streets
forever
he's going to
think megan understand your dick in my
direction
bro she's walking right past me i found
more like i've heard guys say like that
have
money that they would date a girl at
mcdonald's if she had the
characteristics that he was listening
to
it's true it's true it's true it's true
it's true you wouldn't look at someone
that works at mcdonald's
maybe it's a bit more than just being
rich but when you have a status like in
society
celebrity for example
like you don't you don't really find
celebrities dating regular people right
it's not it's not right you know but
correct me if i'm wrong
correct me if i'm wrong here but you see
like some of these male rappers here a
lot of them are up here
a lot of us don't know their girls until
they get with them how did they come up
name one huh name one
yeah couldn't you do um what's your i
didn't hear of um
is his name
you said the couple earlier in the show
it was like a rapper
yeah
i've never heard of india before
what did you introduce
the thing with india she's very
independent regardless of being with
little duck she has her own business
she's doing her own like instagram stuff
like she's got something going on for
herself
he made it better yeah he made it better
because she made it
someone like her wouldn't go for someone
with no status like because she's
obviously
probably saw her and was like
independent
like obviously he's attracted to her
yeah so she's bringing something she
already had a couple hundreds no she's
on 2 000 followers
you're not on the bottom
and she had she had nothing in it so
like maybe but that was before he was
like
that was before he was lit though at
that point because he knew that he
needed something
yes the thing is i'm not i'm not gonna
disagree with that in it but i thought
why do you think so many celebrities
they all like go out with each other bro
well is it is it that you just trade
girlfriends or boyfriends well you don't
think it's because they're around each
other more yeah it's kind of like how
athletes date athletes a lot of the time
because of me like
not me actually oh
girls that you trapped me ain't cutting
it now the thing is i can but i
obviously i'm a spinner in it
sometimes around that fold it's just too
techy like it's just too
it's like imagine like because sometimes
that some people can train the same
group
at first oh yeah you look so cute you're
also running together on track for life
and then whenever
and then let's see youtube now coming to
the place now and then
and then let's see youtube like come to
training nine is like you both like
didn't have like a great day the day
before before the session i said are you
a chat to a girl or something like that
like that's something that people can't
deal with so for me is what is advice i
don't really date athletes in the same
way just athletes in general but you
could see how in general like they would
more because they're around each other
more that's just going to cling on to
you kind of like model state models like
busy you kind of understand the
lifestyle
yeah basically you just have to
understand your partner's lifestyle
do you guys care what job the girl that
you're the girls that you date have no
no just not athletes
so what if she has any friends as a job
ah i've been an only fans can we not do
that
if she's working like legitimately even
if i won't i won't judge she works
she's making her money
and they are working at least you're
working yeah you're actually doing
something here
for me i'd probably want you to aspire
to do more so it wouldn't just be just
working with donors and that's what
you're doing and they'll be like what
else are you doing
with anything but
the job doesn't really get that get that
eight pound ninety five per hour
you know
i saw you that's if you're a manager
yes
what about you do you care what job a
guy has
yes
as long as you're doing something for
yourself
and there's nothing like crazy like you
no porn stuff no corn star sorry no
explicit stuff because at the end of the
day i'd rather keep that private would
you do you care if a guy's like broke
breaking more sense you can't be trying
to come out of me and
doing that chicken change like you know
what i mean
i i feel comfortable in painful food
like i'll pay for our food
it's not
every single time because then i'm like
bro what what what are you doing
you know i don't like leeches have you
ever dated a leech
no i don't think i have no i don't i
like independent people
yeah like people that can take care of
themselves yeah what okay so what if he
made it you can take care of me as well
what if he makes like thirty thousand a
year is that okay
and i study united states yeah that's
that's nothing come on you know that
stuff yes
the standards don't have to be like you
have to be running a mill like
like we actually have to be humble
people at the end of the day because we
are still all human
okay let's say you can't take you out
you know how some guys that really hit
that like they go over the top like look
like we're going to hackathon today
we're going nobu
they just do too much
let's say they can't do that like what
are you saying well first of all i've
never actually been that's fair yeah
but
like
but it's just like
um
i like quality time i like to feel like
if we can actually go to the park and
have a picnic have a good time and enjoy
ourselves
let's do that all right i don't feel
like let's look at something every
single day
because then you're building something
that you can't mention
do you ever feel like if a guy spends
money on you like too soon it turns you
off not not like a date but like where
he's like showering you like i've had
guys where they're like
no i think that that sauce is not what
you want yeah that's that's how i felt
yeah what are you
what
my last boyfriend would offer to send me
like loads of cash all the time i
wouldn't take it because i just feel
like we were dating
he offered to send me like 10k once i
was just like you should have taken it
no
free i would have been yo
no i sort of got because i just i felt
weird taking money from someone i would
have told that in an instant that's
going towards my mortgage rule no
because it doesn't i know i i still
think about it
i feel like if a guy does that he's just
trying to prove a point like oh yeah
he's a provider
come on let's be realistic uh i don't i
don't know what's of it so what what
about all your friends are getting like
showered with gifts and they're just
like snapping they're putting on
instagram
why are they not getting gifts for me
like no like from like the guy like the
guy they're dating like how would that
make you feel like if your guy was just
so let's say your guy can't do that like
he's still doing little things people
that said you can't do you can't do what
they're doing so like going out
okay cool it's not for me but you know
what i mean i would find a way
especially
where there's a way yeah for real but
then again it's like what girl doesn't
want to be showered with gifts you know
that's true
i just i feel like too soon it turns me
off
no i swear to god because i'm like why
you know okay you know what's a weird
turn off i have this is really weird i
kind of i kind of have a thing for cheap
guys i don't know what it is like
i okay because i love i don't know
watching i i love me a good bargain you
know yeah and so when i see guys spend
stupid amounts of money
on clothes
i'm like no and i'm just like
why like it doesn't impress me it makes
me think you're like like if you if you
only make so much money and you're
spending this much on your wardrobe i'm
like why no but it has to make sense
like if you have that lifestyle where
you can do that enjoy yourself in it
yeah that's what if it's not making
sense and you can't pay your phone bill
we are still dropping seven bills on the
shoes then we have a problem
no um first yeah yeah
yeah
just the expectations yes
imagine knocking on your boy's door with
a goose and balances i'll pay for my
phone please i'll run about next month
now it just goes back to socials bro
because you see on social media like you
see someone post like all these bags of
stuff in the hotel and it's like raw
like that's what you should be doing and
in reality it's not there's people
there's so many people no it is it's so
it's women's fault
it's females fool
i say it's females football i wanted to
say that but i don't know those girls
would just be like
girls would be like if you ain't got a
goose you can't even approach me like
she wouldn't even look twice in your
direction
if he's not whipping don't chat
like like like he's not even worried
about his phone bill like he's gonna add
her a snap and screenshot it because he
hasn't got data to like do what i mean
but he's got he has to use his breakfast
he's got the goose to get the snaps when
he goes home in the world
just want to get a snack
yeah but those girls end up alone the
ones that are like he's got to do this
this this this and that like
i i always see those girls end up like
by their damn self often often it's the
really pretty girls though yeah that do
that it's so it's so sad often it's like
really like the girls are like the
nights girls like that these girls like
that yeah like you see like for me
you're like these girls like that like
you know so just because like you're a
10-10 looks you become like when when i
see something like you become like a 5
out of 10 for me do you get it because
it's like
yeah you're lying and you have all the
looks and that but it's like just if
you're putting someone if you're putting
so much pressure for someone like bro
like what are you doing for yourself
type of thing
like something goes because i can't
elaborate i'm a materialistic girl so
like
be ready to like be shining with gifts
oh what do you bring to the table are me
it's your head i am the table yes like
what do you mean that and like with some
guys here and i think we're speaking
about this previously as well with some
guys because the girl was so good
looking like like
right if people see you everyone's like
wow he's now going to be doing things
just so he can keep the girl there yeah
so then he then becomes he starts doing
things that he doesn't need to do just
to make the girl happy so cool maybe by
the end of the month he might buy her
new v bag valencies dior's but he can't
even pay his phone bill he can't even
pay for get fulfilled so like and rude
like as dawn said like
sometimes girls do you do that like it
does have a factor
yeah do you guys think that pretty girl
like the prettier the girl the like
more high maintenance she'll be or the
more like do you because i've heard some
guys say that girls that are super hot
are just like for the streets because
they're like like they just have never
had to develop a personality do you
think that's true yeah
i've seen pretty girls have privileges i
promise you okay
they have privileges but there's a lot
of girls i think they don't even know it
they don't even know they have it bro
yeah yeah
actually that's true that doesn't solve
this how do they not know they have it
with instagram i feel like every hot
girl knows she's hot
no but i don't think they're all for the
streets and i don't think they're all
have no personalities i feel like some
of them i feel like some of them even
though they are pretty some of them are
insecure so when they do see that people
like i kind of like going towards them
they need that sort of like validation
validation that yeah they're not but
they're not actually you know you know
what it tends to be you know you know
the pretty girls yeah because they're
pretty and you see on social media like
they get told oh like you look cute did
it whatever whatever no one actually
tells them so you know they're mad
insecure
yeah i'm saying because no one like
significant
like is actually telling them like you
look beautiful today
they don't have there's none of that
it's just this random person or this
random creep
it doesn't really mean anything yeah so
that's what i mean by a lot of people
won't even
necessarily realize let's say what they
are capable of
getting or doing let's say if they just
wasn't into leech or things like that
obviously some girls tap in early and
clock it mm-hmm something
i'm saying the move kind of free with it
because i don't know with pretty
privileged it's a thing though like it
is a thing it's real i realized that
it's very really it's real i realized
that but i wasn't i feel like within
myself my confidence wasn't there before
like
personality was always that was always
there for me but in terms of looks like
you kind of develop into
what you kind of look like now type
thing in terms of growth yeah in terms
of growth because i look back at myself
a few years ago i think what is that
mm-hmm
[Laughter]
[Music]
i think i think the curse of girls that
are really attractive
is so if you're a girl and you're an
eight because this is kind of how the
red pill filters out looks so we don't
really do sevens because seven everyone
thinks they're seven you ask most people
what do you rate yourself one to ten
most people say seven
you have to either pick you're pretty
enough to be a model or you're not so
you're eight to ten is model worthy five
six is like pretty cute okay five six so
that's i would say because five five is
average most people are average
okay but i'm saying this is why this is
what i'm saying though this scale is
like different because it's it's more
realistic because in real life most
people are average if you meet
100 people most people have to be in the
middle
like there's no other way you could do
it guys the guys know that on the scale
six is that average-ish seven get away
okay okay yeah
okay telling you guys
so this is how i do the scale there's no
seven sevens don't exist because
everyone thinks they're seven
so you can't do it you're either pretty
enough to be a model so you're eight
nine or ten that means you could get a
modeling contract someone would pay you
for your looks that's how good looking
you are five sixes you're pretty cute
like you wouldn't model but you're cute
like you you're not gonna have a hard
time getting the opposite sex okay
so i think the problem is with eight
nines and tens is that those girls have
access to like they got like the guys
that are eights nines and tens right
because that's and those guys have a
hard time being faithful because they
have access to everybody hey
you know what i was actually having this
conversation not too long ago
too bro you can't just do the guys
options
but guys and girls are different though
why is yeah
girls keep their options bro sneaky
links bro how long can you have do you
know what i'm saying like yeah obviously
yeah you know you know when you know
when that one options are mm-hmm one of
them has money feeding it the other one
is just there to kill you through when
you're upset the other one has good
feelings
bro that's where it goes
but here's the difference though is
girls want commitment and guys want sex
so here's the difference like
like a girl you could you could have sex
with anyone it's easy for you but guys
have to like earn sex that's next
girls girls and girls have to earn
commitment
so that's what i'm saying like
like
those girls want commitment maybe not
from every guy they talk to they
probably do use some guys for attention
and validation that's true but every
girl has the one guy she actually wants
she may be talking to ten she has like
one maybe two that she actually wants
and and getting but i'm saying but i'm
saying like getting
maybe the one that you want
no but that's what i'm saying because
because those guys how how do you lock
that guy down when he has the uh like as
a dude dude if you have the option to
sleep with everyone why wouldn't like
for starters you don't speak to the ten
that's how you that's how you knock him
down you know yeah because then he will
think but then girls are told what never
settle
is life
you know do you know they're they're
projecting that half of women today will
be single and childless by like 40 huh
because i even feel like the the value
of marriage is dying like that just died
i'm so sorry it died
it died
and commitment stuff like it is a bit of
a that's true because you see you see
sometimes when the girl goes i'm like oh
the date was nice i think i might let
him wait for a bit i remind him i'm
almost there i'm almost there almost
there all right girls are letting me hit
man oh guys i did it i did it rude
that's literally that's actually mitchy
way israel like
he's trying to score and she's thinking
like let me just stretch it out when it
finally happens yeah and then they leave
you and it's like
my theory is yeah
this is this is free game for you guys
don't
don't chase girls they they've got
10 other guys that they're attracted to
that's attracted to them if you're that
one person that doesn't chase them for
some reason they're gonna you you've got
their attention so they're gonna they're
gonna be true they're gonna be thinking
about you it's true and then she's gonna
be like
wondering what you're doing and then
yeah like i don't know you're going to
do with that information but
the first one don't be the chaser yeah
don't chase
that's true that's true because
because it almost makes them like higher
value because they're like well why
didn't he chase me yeah literally and
then it doesn't make sense but they
won't they want you to chase them so
they're going to do things to make you
want to chase them no you don't need to
chase them
i'm telling you
i thought you guys like a bit of a chase
no there's a little it can't be too easy
but you can't be stretching it oh when
they when they start dragging it that's
when you fall back that's when you fall
back and then
everyone else is gonna be messaging her
and she's gonna be like where's this guy
like why is he not you know like you
know that message i got all these guys
after you and you're here playing games
we got another super chat question okay
so
fellows fellas would you rather have an
agreeable 304
or a mean virgin
[Music]
so three or four is like a hoe
a good thought for the streets
like an agreement oh do you do an
agreeable means
um okay so agreeable means like kind
nice like compassionate caring she's a
nice host
yeah she's a nicer or a mean virgin
at the time marriage so like girl you
settle down
[Music]
we don't want a mean girl though
she's just a nice girl bro like she's
just friendly she's not as cute and not
like
she's like she's
if she's not you want a nice girl bro
you don't want a girl that's gonna be
like oh i had a game today she was like
okay like even though she a virgin
she's mean like she's mean to you bro
she makes you feel like you're what
looks bro
it might be coming back after [ __ ] game
terrible day
literally might have to come after a bad
game
what's wrong with you
after you get them they're not going to
continue to be a whole and if they are
then you're out in it but if you stay
then you're just stupid
[Music]
like
that's why like you can't really judge
the past too much but everyone does it
anyway but it's only so much but that's
the thing you can enjoy your chat like
you can enjoy your young time but don't
destroy it bro like yeah i'm like if you
tell someone that r called this my bc is
this much here like cool like you were
younger and there's always there's
always contests to it more that's what
i'm saying like
some could be relationships some could
be you're just having fun but it's a
thing where
if you're still a steady person i'm cool
you just slept around
not that bad but if right like bro
imagine like you're the gm [ __ ]
sorry
like do you know what though you know i
would say
would you prefer your your girl being
mean to everyone including you or your
girl being nice to everyone to everyone
that's what i'm saying that's what i'm
saying that's what i'm saying like so
that's why the question's a bit shaky
because i don't know you guys actually
being friendly gives guys the wrong idea
like like what moms were saying earlier
like he's gonna be there like he's gonna
go to his boys your girl's gonna like
she's got a boyfriend he's gonna go to
his ways and be like oh yeah man i think
she's feeling me still like yeah look at
this chat wait wait what
wait wait wait wait wait i need to i
need to i need to break this down
let's let's let's break this down don't
know so it's okay let's say let's say
you two are dating right yeah so so in
love great and if she says hi to him
yeah
then he's gonna go
and say oh she's feeling like like how
does this work
there's a difference
because if she's being friendly like
like like
when i'm talking to him if she's giving
him more than what he needs like in a
conversation it could be on text in
person you can sense when someone is
being your friend and you can sense when
or you can have a sense when that all
right
like imagine you say something like the
girl just grabs your arms oh my god
you're so funny literally they were like
yeah i finally
seen flirty at that point it's not even
like really talking laughing that's
friendly but when you come to touching
you're like oh my god you know what i
mean that's funny so let me let me let
me just understand so instead of then
going to your friend and being like yo
your girl's a hug like you you tell the
other friends
guys
i'm just wondering
within a group chat yeah there could be
eight of us in a group chat in that
group chat we have our individual
friendships in that group chat yeah
everyone's speaking to twos and threes i
promise you i promise you in every group
chat you split into twos and threes so
always
like
okay okay if your woman has a girlfriend
and
she's kind of talking to me i'm not
going to show anyone else i might show
reese i might be like yo bro look at
this girl like like she's even loosen it
like do you get like i'm not going to go
and tell my machine
i want to tell him and see what he's
saying because i might be like taking it
wrong i couldn't even like i could be
like seeing it because sometimes guys
like you're just being nice and they'll
think you're flirting
that's what i'm saying
i'm a chit chatter like sometimes i'm
like
[Music]
we're talking it's just convo fair
enough but then let's say now i go
i'm not a random person so you don't
know me at all yeah and i go oh like
what's your snapchat let's talk and then
you give me your snack
i'm looking at you like yeah
like this could be your new friend
what um there's business related stuff
like say you do um
like photography and i've been looking
for a photographer
then we bring business into it
that's how that's how early fans started
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's the thing it could be business or
you've given him yes yeah you've given
him like your snap or your number or
your answer whatever
photography
and then
i can see you're messaging them about
something that is not photography
related yeah yeah
then you're asking him like what did he
do today and i'm just like what do you
mean what did he do today like why
why do you care what he was doing today
like why'd you like yeah
yeah like it's good see i wouldn't
expect i wouldn't give a guy my snapper
my number in a bar club setting if i
wasn't interested that's true but
sometimes like i'll just
that's very crucial
honestly like when i'm in a relationship
when i'm when i'm in a relationship i
don't go out
like i feel like what are you like what
are you going to do for me about my mom
i stay home bro
there's different ways you guys can have
fun in it yeah i mean like i just don't
know what else yeah like i'll go out to
lunch or maybe do a pub but like like
clubbing
hotels together but
what
it's enjoyable but i don't know
i don't like pre-determine like oh yeah
i'm gonna go clubbing car i want to pull
did it yeah that's not it
obviously if you chat to someone when
you're there and you want to speed
someone up it happens
[Music]
do you know what it is that couldn't be
your motive but like 95 of the guys in
there
if my goal was to say i'm going clubbing
in my head i'm thinking like oh
there's 95 percent guys like five
percent of the guys are gonna be there
are going to be interested in you
because you're pretty anyway yeah but is
that not your own
that's what you have to trust
yeah i don't mind that yeah because then
you don't want to portray that i think
yes
[Music]
you're just going to be laying there
like thinking like what is this girl
doing right now like but that's where
trust comes in really yes
this is how you know you've won that's
how you know she's friendly that's how
you know she's one no this is how you
know you've won in the club yet if she
facetimes you and you she knows what she
can't hear
do you guys okay what do you guys think
if you're in a relationship and a girl
posts a thirst trap do you think that's
disrespectful to you what is the point
yeah wait why you might go in the first
place
i've had this black before yeah i'm
joking by the way no no names thinking
that she came to me and was like look
i'm gonna post i'm gonna post this and
it was like a bikini picture or whatever
and that but she's like she does all the
fitness and stuff
she told you about it yeah i could be
like alright cool
but and it's it's always different let's
say you met a girl and that's how she's
been posting yeah you can't you can't
you can't you can't tell her to stop
yeah you can't you can't if a girl
dresses a certain way
before you met them you met them you
like them for that and now you're going
to continue you can't know all of a
sudden yeah you're going to have to know
what you're looking for
yeah yeah yeah
that's my girl what she was doing though
if my girl
has never posted a picture like that in
her life and then all of a sudden
i'm on social media i'm flicking through
and i see that and i tap off it because
then i'll go back and be like what i'll
just be like let's just go crazy like
[ __ ] over yeah no no any of my problems
always just come from when something
changes if that's how you've been all
the time before i've had no problems
yeah but now all of a sudden you want to
go do this and that out of the ordinary
that's what i'm like yeah
i'll tell you guys my stories i promise
i'm telling you
i made agreements with certain people
that listen on tv live tv youtube twitch
whatever i can't really bear the
information in it i won't see anybody
know who they are in it but there's some
that i can discuss but
is that is that it
is it a red flag do you guys if a girl
has like her butt and her like body all
over her is that's what attracted me so
if
that's what attracted me and i've now
spoken to you and we're now together now
i can't really complain tonight no i'm
asking like like so when you date now
i'm not saying like if that attracted
you i'm saying would that attract you
like to date a girl
yeah it depends again yeah it depends
depends depends what pictures they are
not cause no i hear it though because
there's some girls that do fitness and
they wear bikinis in that or whatever in
it yeah she does finish those fitness
bro like there's even some girls like
they wear bikinis and they're walking to
the gym oh do you see the fruit shaking
left and right
i can't lie
oh my god
let me let me learn and there's a thing
where cool just fruits you can't help it
in it but
like that's not the purpose of the video
but whereas there's some girls like
they're just posting
because they know they got
freeze and it's like they just want
everyone to be playing out their
comments together there's them girls
that are actually like that so i feel
like it's just the most if you have if
you're going on holiday i mean you're
not going to wear a tracksuit on the
beach and take a picture if you have a
bikini and they're taking pictures of
your girls and you're going to do them
pauses there's nothing wrong with that
but it's not when you're now doing them
wild positions now and i'm thinking
oh wow
yeah right yeah
something changes often all of a sudden
you want to take one picture
and you know what the thing is for some
girls like when they decide to change
things up and you ask them why they they
can't come they
they come up with some dumb reason
like yeah but i just
sure man like
have you
have you ever seen that clip that's like
going viral by fresh and fit where he
says if you have an instagram and you're
in a relationship that's cheating
yeah i saw that i can't lie that was
awesome
that
[Music]
would you if a guy was taking care of
all the bills
you're you're super attracted to this
guy really into him and he says okay i
just don't date girls with instagram so
if you want to be with me you got to
delete the instagram would you do it
she's doing it
social media
i'm living i'm chilling if you're not
no
he's
she doesn't really need to be doing her
own thing if he's going to take care of
everything it depends what you're using
it for yeah for me
instagram just a look
it's not like it's my business right now
or anything like that i feel like
instagram is kind of interesting as well
you know i mean you think you're just
making like a spam account interesting
sometimes
i have answers
you can actually find so much on it
do you think social media ruins
relationships yep it has yes it has
it's been
it's still going to this is
the quotes i started seeing during
lockdown if he's not doing this if he
can't do that he's not the one justin
the boy ruined relationships
respectfully justin check him out
he he he he ruins he ruin
it's like a comment it's like oh if your
girl was doing it
it's like wrong you start deep in like
bro
i've never seen this nah there was one
look
[Music]
so much things you can relate to it's
just like you just deep live bro
[Music]
once i feel disrespected that [ __ ] kills
all my feelings you'll never you'll
think i never
had none for you hashtag respectfully
you know the guys that post this the
most emotional ones those guys
[Laughter]
you'll hear from him next week
loves what
private studies
how to f nobody in my family rich what
was y'all doing back in the day
hashtag i don't know how did this ruin
relationships
he posts he posts like
relates quotes
oh okay
i'm gonna find one for you guys
yeah my baby daddy lied men do want me
and my kids
i'm so understanding so i'd be mad when
people lie to me or move weird because
it's like all you had to do was talk to
me
you could have just spoke about it and
we wouldn't have an issue
if she doesn't call you drunk
she's you ain't excited you're at him
boy i said that you ate him boys
[Music]
bro you could be winning every game on
fifa as soon as that mind comes in
you're losing bro you can just be
enjoying her now exactly
yeah
facetime
imagine your girl goes out clubbing
you're scrolling through insta it's like
2 a.m you're waiting for her to get home
safe whatever you might be staying
together whatever
it's going to 2 a.m you see that post if
she's she's out drunk and she ain't
called you oh you are not him how are
you going to feel with just laying down
you're losing every game on fifa you're
laying there and
do you guys think it's the other way
around too that if he doesn't call you
when he's drunk
then when she comes in i'm going to be
salty towards her likes
where were you bro
like babe i had the most amazing like
yeah i'm going to bed like
literally
don't touch me
don't touch you know you know that's the
worst like when you read something here
and like you relate to so much hits you
just still [ __ ] it hits home
it hits home
that's true
okay i have another super chat to read
um thank you mgtow by logic i do
um let me see if there's any more i
think that was only one the 304. okay
guys um i think we're going to close out
the show on that so before we end why
don't you guys go around tell the people
where they can find you and any closing
thoughts that you have
oh so you can go first yeah go ahead or
you can find your socials on ig advm
5k
um
um but yeah i think there's a lot of
different perspectives that we talked
about today
and yeah like
mind opening really
how some of our friends think
would you would you still date a single
mom
yeah actually answer that question
okay yeah you oh so to find me um
yeah and i kind of i really enjoyed them
the podcast like there was a lot of you
know thoughts
and you know opinion shared and kind of
really opened your eyes to like a lot of
things that actually go on
and yeah would i still date a single mom
yes i would actually i would anyway so
so if there's any single moms watching
all their dm's are open
okay hit them up they'll raise they'll
be stuck daddy
they'll look after you
[Music]
but where's the finally louisa
j-l-o-u-i-s-a-j-a-e
underscore on instagram and same for
tick tock and youtube
yeah um
i don't know any advice you guys just
independent females that's all i want to
see 2022
yeah all right my advice is just be
respectful to everyone
live your best life but just know what
you're doing at the same time
where to find me um
on instagram a-n-k-d dot
n d-a-r-n-s so that's angst dot dons and
go check out
and fit ssb loaded on youtube
check out check out my boys bryan
norwin's about losses nwl
and yeah just be safe
you guys can find me at four reese
that's four with like two s at the end
as well um
these guys already said earphones i'm
not even gonna do too much but yeah
okay well thank you guys all for coming
i couldn't do it
i couldn't i couldn't do it without the
guests so i always appreciate people
coming um on top of that guys don't
forget to subscribe to the channel okay
literally i'm trying to hit i'm really
close
to 30k i'm i need i need like 200 more
subs to get to 30. yeah
so let's let's get to 30k thank you so
much for supporting the streams guys um
we're starting to get to the point where
i can like actually hire people soon so
every donation it really really helps um
don't forget to subscribe and i will
talk to you guys next